OK, three boys, aged 13, 15, and 16. All three chose to appear with fake names on this radio program. And the fake names they chose, you ready? K-Rad, Mr. Warez, and Fred. Those first two names come from the world of computer hacking and software piracy. Mr. Warez, for example, that's "warez," as in "wares," as in "softwares," as in pirated softwares, illegal softwares. And as for Fred--
好的，三名男孩，分别是13岁、15岁和16岁。他们三人都选择在这个广播节目中使用化名。而他们选择的化名，准备好了吗？K-Rad、Mr. Warez和Fred。前两个名字来自计算机黑客和软件盗版领域。比如Mr. Warez，就是“warez”，也就是“wares”，也就是“softwares”，即盗版软件、非法软件。至于Fred——
Why Fred? For no reason, man. There's got to be someone else named Fred out there.
为什么叫Fred？没理由啊，伙计。外面肯定还有别人叫Fred吧。
You see, anonymity was important given the kinds of things that we were discussing, namely credit card fraud, computer hacking, and the nature of hell. Well, from WBEZ in Chicago, this is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our playhouse stage, small-scale stories of small-scale sin. Stay with us, won't you?
你看，考虑到我们讨论的事情，即信用卡欺诈、计算机黑客和地狱的本质，匿名非常重要。嗯，这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《你的广播剧场》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天在我们的剧场舞台上，上演的是关于小罪恶的小故事。留下来听听，好吗？
So K-Rad, Mr. Warez, and Fred were trying to be criminals. But they were not too successful at this. And at a McDonald's on Times Square in New York City, they told all. Doesn't that have a nice, Hard Copy sound to it? "They told all."
所以K-Rad、Mr. Warez和Fred试图成为罪犯。但他们在这方面不太成功。在纽约时代广场的一家麦当劳里，他们说出了实情。这听起来是不是很有那种《硬拷贝》（Hard Copy）节目的味道？“他们吐露了一切。”
This was kind of an unpleasant McDonald's. Because it was in Times Square, they decided to have neon lights everywhere in this place. A crush of sweaty people at the counter, tourists, most of us. It was the middle of summer. Fred took charge.
这是一家相当不愉快的麦当劳。因为它在时代广场，所以他们决定在店里到处装上霓虹灯。柜台前挤满了汗流浃背的人，大多是游客，我们也是。当时正是盛夏。Fred负责指挥。
What do you guys want?
你们想要什么？
I want a number one meal.
我要一份一号套餐。
OK, I'm paying for this. You're paying for my cab, OK? Whatever I can pay for. OK, we'll have a number one meal.
好吧，我来付钱。你付我的出租车费，好吗？不管我能付得起什么。好吧，我们要一份一号套餐。
They're actually in Manhattan for a computer hackers' convention this summer, and Fred was not used to the downtown prices.
他们今年夏天其实是去曼哈顿参加黑客大会的，Fred不太习惯市中心的消费水平。
Oh my god. It's $5, man. You guys are chipping in. I can't pay for this.
天哪。要5美元，伙计。你们也得出点钱。我付不起这个。
I think it's fair to say that one sign that your criminal career is not going so well is if you have to worry about the prices at McDonald's. But K-Rad, Mr. Warez, and Fred were involved in very low-level types of crimes. All of them involve computers. They pirated software. They scammed free CD-ROM games. They cheated one of the big online computer services out of a few hundred dollars in online time.
我认为可以公平地说，如果你的犯罪生涯还要担心麦当劳的餐费，那就说明它进行得不太顺利。但K-Rad、Mr. Warez和Fred参与的都是极低级的犯罪。所有这些都涉及计算机。他们盗版软件，骗取免费的CD-ROM游戏，还从一家大型在线计算机服务公司骗了几百美元的在线时长费。
All in all, they didn't steal very much. And they didn't steal very effectively. But they did try to steal. Take this phone scam, where they would call people at random and try to get a calling card number or a credit card number out of them.
总而言之，他们偷的东西并不多。偷窃的手段也不高明。但他们确实尝试去偷。就拿这个电话诈骗来说，他们会随机给别人打电话，试图从中骗取通话卡号码或信用卡号码。
Basically, the way it works is this. You call up somebody. You say, "This is the AT&T operator. I have a priority collect call for--" so-and-so's name. And the whole point is you have to sound like you're not calling somebody up with the intention of getting them. You have to sound like you've been sitting in this chair for 10 hours, and you want to go home.
基本上，它的运作方式是这样的。你给某人打电话。你说：“我是AT&T接线员。我这里有一个优先接听的对方付费电话，是打给——”某某人的。重点是你听起来不能像是特意打电话来找他们麻烦的。你得听起来像是已经在椅子上坐了10个小时，想回家了。
So you got to go, "This is the AT&T operator. I have a collect call for Paul. Will you accept charges, sir?" "Uh, yeah. I'll accept charges." "All right, hold on one second."
所以你得说：“我是AT&T接线员。有一个打给保罗的对方付费电话。先生，您接受付费吗？”“呃，是的。我接受付费。”“好的，请稍等。”
Then you tap on the keyboard. You say, "I'm sorry. You seem to have a restriction on your phone line. You can't accept collect calls to this line." And then they yell, and they go, "What do you mean, I can't accept collect calls to my line? I've been getting collect calls to this line for 20 years."
然后你敲击键盘。你说：“抱歉。您的电话线路似乎有限制。您无法接听对方付费电话。”然后他们会大喊大叫，说：“什么意思，我不能接对方付费电话？我20年来一直都在用这条线接对方付费电话。”
And then, you've got to go, "Sir, there's nothing I can do about it. My computer says you can't receive a collect call on this line. Would you like to try an alternate billing method?" In which case they will proceed to either give you a calling card or a major credit card.
然后，你必须说：“先生，我也没办法。我的电脑显示您这条线无法接听对方付费电话。您要尝试其他的付款方式吗？”在这种情况下，他们就会提供通话卡或主要信用卡。
And that, of course, is the idea behind the whole thing, to end up with a calling card number or a credit card number that is not your own, that you can use yourself. Now I should say that before you go out and try this yourselves, if you are thinking about doing this yourself right now, I should tell you one important fact. It doesn't work.
当然，这就是整个计划背后的想法，最终得到一个不属于你自己的通话卡号码或信用卡号码，供你自己使用。现在我要说的是，在你出去尝试之前，如果你现在正考虑这么做，我得告诉你一个重要的事实：这行不通。
The reason it doesn't work is because a good percentage of people, after the point at which they go through the mind-boggling experience of not understanding what it means to have a restriction on your line, because nobody knows what that means, then they'll just say, "Oh, this is too much trouble. Forget it. I won't accept the collect call."
行不通的原因是，很大一部分人在经历了这种令人难以置信的困惑，即不明白为什么电话线路会被限制——因为没人知道那是什么意思——之后，他们只会说：“哦，这太麻烦了。算了。我不接这个对方付费电话了。”
The other scams these guys run don't do much better. They tried to hack their way into the mainframe system of a big computer retailer. But they were caught and stopped before they got very far. They are such unaccomplished computer hackers that Fred himself was actually the victim of computer hackers twice. Someone broke into Fred's account on one computer bulletin board and used his account and his electronic mail to visit some of the nether regions of the net.
这些人搞的其他诈骗也没好到哪里去。他们曾试图黑进一家大型计算机零售商的主机系统。但在他们走得太远之前就被抓到并制止了。他们是非常不入流的黑客，Fred本人甚至两次成为黑客受害者。有人闯入了Fred在某个计算机公告板上的账户，并利用他的账户和电子邮件访问了一些网络的阴暗角落。
Remember, you talked to the guy on IRC. There's this weird guy. This guy was going on all these sex channels. And he was wrecking my name and stuff. It was awful.
记得你和IRC上的那个家伙谈过吗？有个奇怪的家伙。这家伙跑遍了所有色情频道。他在破坏我的名声之类的。太糟糕了。
You can't get pissed at him. I wouldn't get pissed at him, because that would be entirely hypocritical. I've said that if anybody ever steals one of my credit cards or ever hacks into my account or computer system, I will not care. And I will be perfectly allowable to that.
你不能生他的气。我不会生他的气，因为那完全是虚伪的。我说过，如果有人偷了我的信用卡或者黑进了我的账户或计算机系统，我不会在意。这完全是可以接受的。
To go and say, "I can't believe it. Somebody took my credit card." Well, so what if I did it to everyone else? I'm perfectly willing to let someone do that to me.
去说“我真不敢相信。有人拿了我的信用卡。”好吧，如果我也对别人做了同样的事，那又怎样？我完全愿意让别人对我做同样的事。
Over the summer was when they really started to get serious about using other people's credit cards, which they call "carding." They met a guy who was good at this and who taught them some tricks. K-Rad and Fred ordered $1,600 in computer merchandise on someone else's credit card. They had it delivered to a neutral address. They picked it up. They sold half of it for cash.
今年夏天，他们才真正开始认真考虑使用别人的信用卡，他们称之为“盗刷”（carding）。他们遇到了一个擅长此道的人，并教了他们一些技巧。K-Rad和Fred用别人的信用卡订购了价值1600美元的计算机商品。他们让人送到一个中立的地址。他们去取货，然后把一半卖掉换成现金。
And one thing that's peculiar about this story is that these are rich kids. K-Rad and Fred live in a wealthy upstate community. They attend what is one of the most expensive, prestigious private schools in the country. But they steal.
这个故事有一个奇怪的地方，那就是这些孩子都是富家子弟。K-Rad和Fred住在郊区一个富裕的社区。他们就读于全国最昂贵、最负盛名的私立学校之一。但他们还是偷窃。
Fred believes that he has no choice. He really suffers over money. He's this skinny, young-looking 15-year-old. And he is perpetually strapped for cash. And he said that his parents couldn't help him much with money right now because they had just gone $500,000 into debt.
Fred认为他别无选择。他真的为钱所困。他是个身材瘦削、看起来很年轻的15岁男孩。他总是缺钱。他说他父母现在没法在钱上帮他太多，因为他们已经背负了50万美元的债务。
Because they bought a house right before the depression and stuff. The recession, excuse me. I consider it a depression. I've noticed the effects.
因为他们在萧条之前买了房子之类的。是衰退，抱歉。我把它看作是萧条。我已经注意到了它的影响。
At one point, to get some cash, he actually sold the computer that his parents had bought for him. And I don't think they knew. His idea is that he wanted to replace the computer as quickly as he could with the help of a stranger's credit card.
有一次，为了弄点钱，他甚至卖掉了父母给他买的电脑。我觉得他们不知道。他的想法是，他想在陌生人信用卡的帮助下尽快把电脑买回来。
And he also wanted to get all the other things that the other kids at his expensive private school had. He wanted to have a microwave. He wanted to have a stereo. Basically, he just wanted to be like everybody else.
他还想得到他在昂贵的私立学校里其他孩子拥有的所有东西。他想要微波炉。他想要立体声设备。基本上，他只是想和别人一样。
I'm also pretty good at shoplifting. But my whole thing on that is that I will not steal anything if I have the money for it. And a lot of times, like the store at my school, like the grill, I steal from that a lot. But I also give them $10 for no reason if I have the money because I feel bad about what I've stolen. And if I ever get the money so I don't have to do this shit anymore, then I'm not going to do it.
我也很擅长顺手牵羊。但我对此的原则是，如果我有钱，我就不会偷东西。很多时候，比如我们学校的商店，像烧烤店，我经常从那里偷东西。但如果我有钱，我也会无缘无故地给他们10美元，因为我觉得偷了东西很内疚。如果我哪天有了钱，不用再做这些破事了，那我就不会再做了。
What's striking about this is how these boys want to convince themselves-- I think they really do-- want to convince themselves that they are good, and that what they do does not harm anyone. And if it does harm someone, there's always the reassuring thought that they keep very near at hand that someday they can make it up to the injured party.
最引人注目的是这些男孩是如何想要说服自己——我想他们确实是——想要说服自己他们是好人，他们的所作所为不会伤害任何人。如果真的伤害了某人，他们身边总有一个令人安心的想法：迟早有一天他们可以补偿受害者。
As noble as this sounds, this is one thing that I absolutely guarantee that sounds like the biggest load of crap anyone could ever say. But if I am ever in a financial--
这听起来很高尚，但我绝对保证，这听起来是任何人能说的最扯淡的话。但如果我哪天陷入财务——
We believe in you.
我们相信你。
No, no one should believe in me. This is the biggest "I'm really good inside." If I ever find myself-- and I've made this vow to myself-- in a good enough financial situation, I will repay everything I have ever done now. If I find myself making $2 million a year, I will send a $10,000 check to the company which I stole calling cards from. That is something I definitely want to do if I am in the financial situation to do it.
不，谁都不该相信我。这纯粹是那种“我内心其实很好”的说法。如果我哪天发现自己——我已经对自己发过誓——财务状况足够好了，我会偿还我现在做过的一切。如果我发现自己年入200万，我会给那家我偷过通话卡的公司寄一张1万美元的支票。如果我有经济条件的话，那是我绝对想做的事。
K-Rad told me that the $1,600 that they charged to a stranger's Visa card was, in fact, a victimless crime, that the card owner would call Visa, have the charge removed from his bill. And that Visa figures a certain amount of fraud is just the cost of doing business.
K-Rad告诉我，他们盗刷陌生人Visa卡的1600美元，其实是一起没有受害者的犯罪，卡主会给Visa打电话，要求从账单上扣除这笔费用。而Visa认为一定程度的欺诈只是做生意的成本。
One thing that I've always said in all my doings is that I will never, ever do something that will severely hurt an individual person. OK? So for example, if it involves-- I would never mug someone. I would never beat someone up for money. I'd never shoplift. Well, maybe I-- no, I wouldn't shoplift.
我在所有行为中一直说的一件事是，我永远、永远不会做严重伤害个人的事情。好吗？比如，如果涉及——我永远不会抢劫别人。我永远不会为了钱殴打别人。我永远不会顺手牵羊。嗯，也许我——不，我不会顺手牵羊。
That's one of my favorite parts of the interview. Hold on. I'm just going to play that tape back. Because you can actually hear him-- he's struggling so much, you can actually hear him working it out out loud. Hold on, I'm just going to rewind for a second.
这是我最喜欢的采访片段之一。等等。我这就把磁带倒回去。因为你可以真切地听到他——他挣扎得太厉害了，你可以听到他在大声理清思路。等等，我倒回去一下。
[TAPE REWINDING]
[磁带倒带声]
--never beat someone up for money. I'd never shoplift. Well, maybe I-- no, I wouldn't shoplift. Because that is hurting the individual person.
——永远不会为了钱殴打别人。我永远不会顺手牵羊。嗯，也许我——不，我不会顺手牵羊。因为那是伤害个人。
See what I mean? So we headed out of the McDonald's and back to the hotel where the computer hackers' convention was taking place. On the way, without any prompting at all, Fred elaborated on the idea that he was only stealing because he absolutely had to.
明白我的意思了吗？于是我们离开麦当劳，回到了黑客大会所在的酒店。路上，没有任何提示，Fred详细阐述了他只有在绝对必要时才去偷窃的想法。
I go to boarding school. And I don't have that much-- I don't have any money or anything. And I get really hungry and stuff. I have a fast metabolism. And seriously, I starve. And I lost 10 pounds in one week. And that's not good for someone who's really skinny, like I am. And then a lot of it is just stuff I want, you know?
我上寄宿学校。我没有那么多——我没钱之类的。我真的很饿。我的新陈代谢很快。说真的，我饿坏了。我一周瘦了10磅。对于像我这样本来就很瘦的人来说，这可不好。还有很多只是我想要的东西，你知道吗？
And yeah, I just really want to stress that in other ways, we're not bad people. And we don't go around trying to screw all people in any way we can. Because we're not at all.
是的，我真的想强调，在其他方面，我们并不是坏人。我们不会到处试图以任何方式坑害所有人。因为我们根本不是那样的人。
I mean, I do social work. I tutored kids. I do a lot of stuff which isn't necessarily evil and more good. But sometimes, it's just like, I don't know, man. I like doing it. I can't explain it.
我的意思是，我做社会工作。我辅导孩子。我做很多不一定邪恶反而有益的事情。但有时候，这就像，我不知道，伙计。我喜欢这样做。我说不清楚。
Talk about that part of it. What is the thrill of doing it?
谈谈那部分吧。那样做的快感是什么？
That's the first-- that was the reason I started carding. The reason was the thrill of going. When we went in there, it was like Mission: Impossible. We went in. We had gloves on and stuff. And we picked it up. We had it all worked out. We were connected. We had lookouts and stuff. And it's just a lot of fun. It's like you're doing stuff that is not exactly legal, not legal at all. And it's fun.
那是最初——那是我开始盗刷的原因。原因就是那种快感。当我们进去的时候，就像《碟中谍》。我们进去了。我们戴着手套之类的。我们拿到了东西。我们都计划好了。我们有联系。我们有放风的人。这真的很有趣。就像你在做一些不完全合法，甚至根本不合法的事情。这很有趣。
By this point, we were back in the hotel lobby. We took the elevators up to the floor where the hackers' convention was taking place. K-Rad said that real hackers do not use their skills like this. They do not use their skills for personal gain. They don't do carding. They don't steal.
到了这个点，我们回到了酒店大堂。我们乘电梯上了黑客大会所在的楼层。K-Rad说，真正的黑客不会这样使用他们的技能。他们不会为了个人利益使用技能。他们不搞盗刷。他们不偷窃。
The whole idea of computer hacking, for these guys anyway, is that it's a kind of pure, zen pursuit. It's an ends in itself. You break into the computer for its own sake and to look around, and for the knowledge of everyone, especially you.
对于这些人来说，计算机黑客技术的全部意义在于，这是一种纯粹的、禅宗式的追求。它是目的本身。你为了黑客技术本身而闯入计算机，为了看看四周，为了让每个人，特别是你自己获得知识。
We stood in the hallway. People streamed by. We tried to move to a corner where we would not be overheard. And K-Rad said, actually, that they had never really talked about their illegal activities this much before with anyone.
我们站在走廊里。人们从我们身边走过。我们试图移到一个不会被听到的角落。K-Rad说，实际上，他们以前从没跟任何人谈过这么多关于他们非法活动的事。
The most thing I'm worried about is I'm actually starting, for the first time, to say this all out loud, everything I've done. And suddenly, it doesn't sound as hacker, much, anymore. And I've known that ever since I moved into doing maybe some credit card thing. And that's why I'm, in fact, even considering giving up on doing all the carding and stuff like that, which seriously, I am.
我最担心的是，我实际上是第一次大声说出这一切，我所做的一切。突然间，这听起来不再那么像黑客行为了。自从我开始搞信用卡诈骗以来我就知道了。这就是为什么我实际上甚至在考虑放弃所有的盗刷之类的行为，说真的，我正在考虑。
Fred then shot him this look. Because if K-Rad were serious, and they did stop carding, Fred would not be able to get a computer to replace the old one that his parents gave him.
Fred随后递给他一个眼神。因为如果K-Rad是认真的，而他们停止了盗刷，Fred就没法搞到一台电脑来替换他父母给他的那台旧电脑了。
What about my computer?
那我那台电脑呢？
What?
什么？
Your computer will come first.
你的电脑要排在第一位。
Jesus Christ, man. I want to get a gun and shoot you.
天哪，伙计。我真想拿把枪毙了你。
All right, after your computer.
好吧，在你那台电脑之后。
The thing about a bad conscience is that it splits you in half. And Fred said that he had two different modes. That was the word he used, "modes." He said that sometimes he would think about what they were doing. And he knew it was wrong, and it would bother him. But mostly, he tried not to think about it.
良心不安的事在于它会把你劈成两半。Fred说他有两种不同的模式。这就是他用的词，“模式”。他说有时他会思考他们正在做的事情。他知道这是错的，这会困扰他。但大多数时候，他试图不去想它。
My worst fear is that I can end up going to hell for doing this. And that's my worst fear.
我最害怕的是，我最终会因为做这些事而下地狱。这是我最大的恐惧。
Do you believe in hell?
你相信地狱吗？
Yeah, I do.
是的，我相信。
And you think you can go to hell for getting a computer on somebody else's credit card?
你觉得你会因为用别人的信用卡买电脑而下地狱吗？
I don't know. I hope not. I really hope not. It's always been my biggest fear. That's why I'm afraid of dying. I'm afraid if there's something I've done which just is like the straw on the camel's back, that's going to be what's going to do it.
我不知道。我希望不会。我真的希望不会。这一直是我最大的恐惧。这就是我害怕死亡的原因。我害怕如果我做过什么事，就像压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草，那可能就是导致这一切的原因。
How big is this worry? Will this keep you up at night?
这种担心有多大？这会让你彻夜难眠吗？
Yeah, maybe for a couple minutes. And then I just sort of put it out of my mind, you know?
会，也许会担心几分钟。然后我就把它抛在脑后了，你知道吗？
His share of the carding profits was $800. I told him that from an adult's perspective, this did not seem like a lot of money. I didn't think you could do eternity in hell for $800.
他分到的盗刷利润是800美元。我告诉他，从成年人的角度来看，这看起来并不是很多钱。我不认为你能为了800美元在地狱里呆上永恒。
And as soon as I said this, I really regretted it. Fred's body language changed completely. It was like I was calling him a little kid. It was like saying that he was ridiculous to worry over something so small. It was just one of these moments. He got quieter, and he kind of pulled into himself a little bit.
我话刚出口就后悔了。Fred的肢体语言完全变了。就像我把他当成小孩子一样。就像说他担心这么小的事情很荒谬。这就是其中一个瞬间。他安静了下来，有点缩回了自己的壳里。
Then Mr. Warez spoke up. He said that sure, maybe by adult standards, this wasn't much money. But to them, it was a lot, that it was plenty enough to count.
然后Mr. Warez开口了。他说确实，也许按成年人的标准，这不是很多钱。但对他们来说，这很多，足以说明问题了。
When is hell a possibility? Whenever you think it is, it is. More on this when our program continues.
地狱何时成为一种可能？当你认为它是的时候，它就是。节目继续后将有更多相关内容。
Well, this is Your Radio Playhouse . Now a little radio experiment. We told a Chicago playwright named Jeff Dorchen what K-Rad, Fred, and Mr. Warez said about hell and about sin and about their own relative badness in this world. And we asked Jeff Dorchen to write an original radio play that would pick up the themes where the boys leave off. So here's what he came up with.
好吧，这是《你的广播剧场》。现在做一个小小的广播实验。我们告诉了一位名叫杰夫·多琴（Jeff Dorchen）的芝加哥剧作家，K-Rad、Fred和Mr. Warez关于地狱、关于罪恶以及关于他们在这个世界上相对邪恶程度的看法。我们请杰夫·多琴写了一部原创广播剧，延续这些男孩留下的主题。这就是他的作品。
I'll call.
我跟牌。
Me too.
我也是。
Three 10's.
三个10。
Full house, aces and eights.
葫芦，A和8。
Ooh. What do you got, kid?
哦。你有什么，孩子？
Four diamonds.
四张方块。
You got nothing.
你什么都没有。
See, if you had some where the numbers matched, or if they were in order, and there were five of them. But that, what you have there, that's nothing.
你看，如果你有数字相匹配的，或者它们是连续的，而且有五张。但那个，你手里的那个，那什么都不是。
My grandpa used to call that a kangaroo straight.
我爷爷以前管那叫“袋鼠顺子”。
My dad used to call it a Klondike.
我爸爸以前管它叫“克朗代克”。
Klondike wins the game.
克朗代克赢了。
No, Klondike doesn't win the game. Peter wins the game. Full house wins.
不，克朗代克没赢。彼得赢了。葫芦赢了。
I hate you, Peter.
我讨厌你，彼得。
I don't blame you.
我不怪你。
[WAILING]
[哀号声]
Grandmother, be careful. Grazie.
奶奶，小心点。谢谢。
My deal. Straight, five card draw.
该我发牌了。正规玩法，五张抽牌。
Anything wild?
有百搭牌吗？
No.
没有。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[听不清]
Shut up. Ow. Watch it with those cards, man.
闭嘴。噢。拿牌小心点，伙计。
Sorry.
抱歉。
What's your problem today?
你今天怎么了？
He has sinned.
他犯了罪。
Yeah-- yes, I have. How did you know?
是啊——是的，我犯了。你怎么知道的？
Your eyes. They are the eyes of an accused man, furtive, alert, the eyes of a nervous beast who, once a lover of gambols and jigs and standard metals, has been driven to nocturnal skulking by the pursuit of a relentless predator.
你的眼睛。那是被控之人的眼睛，鬼鬼祟祟，警觉不安，就像一只受惊的野兽；曾经热爱嬉戏、舞蹈和寻常金属的它，如今因为遭到无情捕食者的追捕，被迫在深夜里潜行。
He's got you there. 10,000 lira.
这回他说得对。一万里拉。
Call.
跟注。
Call. Caleb, do you believe in sin?
跟注。迦勒，你相信罪吗？
Hell, no. I believe in damnation, though.
见鬼，不信。但我相信地狱的诅咒。
How can you believe in damnation but not sin?
你怎么能相信诅咒却不相信罪呢？
Predestiny. Take me. I was born damned. I'm cowardly, petty, intolerant, lazy, and just generally destructive. I knew I was damned the first time I heard the word.
宿命论。拿我来说吧，我生来就被诅咒了。我胆小、卑劣、偏执、懒惰，而且总的来说是个破坏者。我在第一次听到那个词时，就知道自己被诅咒了。
Your Calvinism relieves you of the responsibility for improving yourself.
你的加尔文主义让你摆脱了自我提升的责任。
Shut up, kid.
闭嘴，孩子。
[SLAP]
[耳光声]
Ow!
噢！
What are you doing?
你在干什么？
It's all right, GI Joe. I am strong.
没关系，大兵。我很坚强。
Yeah, Pete. The kid can take it. Now give me three.
是啊，皮特。这孩子扛得住。现在给我三张牌。
How many, Dondi?
你要几张，东迪？
Four.
四张。
You can't have four. The most you can have is three.
你不能要四张。最多只能要三张。
OK. I'll take two.
好吧。那我要两张。
And two for the dealer.
庄家也要两张。
5,000.
五千。
Call.
跟注。
Call. What do you have?
跟注。你有什么牌？
A pair of 9's. Dondi?
一对九。东迪呢？
Three onions.
三个洋葱。
Those are spades, not onions. And you're supposed to match the numbers, not the suit, you little spaghetti sucker.
那是黑桃，不是洋葱。而且你应该凑数字，而不是花色，你这个吃意面的小混蛋。
I have a Klondike.
我凑了个克朗代克。
You have garbage. How many times do we have to go through this? It's like rolling a boulder up a hill just to have it roll back down again, over and over and over.
你凑了一堆垃圾。我们到底要重复多少次？这简直就像把一块巨石推上山，结果它又滚了下来，反反复复，没完没了。
I will not make the mistake again, sahib.
我不会再犯同样的错误了，长官。
Don't call me sahib. Peter, what do you have? A pair of jacks. All right. Pair of jacks takes it. All right. Seven card stud poker, one-eyed royalty, red deuces, nines, and all odd-numbered clubs are wild.
别叫我长官。皮特，你有什么？一对J。好吧。一对J赢了。好了。七张梭哈扑克，单眼的人头牌、红色二点、九点，以及所有奇数点数的草花都是百搭牌。
What do you guys think the worst sin is? Murder?
你们觉得最严重的罪是什么？谋杀吗？
Betrayal.
背叛。
Why do you say that?
为什么这么说？
At the center of the ninth and innermost frozen circle of hell, Lucifer devours Judas eternally.
在地狱第九层也是最核心的冰封地带中心，路西法正永恒地啃食着犹大。
Really?
真的吗？
That's what they say. One million lira.
人们是这么说的。一百万里拉。
I'll see that and raise you one.
我跟了，再加一百万。
Call.
跟注。
I'm there.
我跟。
What do you got?
你有什么？
Seven aces.
七张A。
Me too.
我也是。
So do I. All right, so there were a few too many wild cards. Let's hold the pot over.
我也是。好吧，看来百搭牌多了点。这局彩池留到下一把吧。
OK. Peter?
好的。皮特？
Huh? Oh, sure. Leave it over. Do you think a sin is worse if say you, for example, you betray somebody? Then suppose you don't feel any remorse. Does that make it worse?
嗯？噢，当然。留着吧。你觉得如果一个人背叛了某人，罪会更重吗？如果之后他没有感到任何悔意呢？这会让罪变得更重吗？
Of course. Gentlemen, the game is Chicago low. Ace, no face, sevens, follow the queen.
当然。各位，现在玩芝加哥低分局。A为底，无花色牌，七点，跟随红桃Q。
Wait a second, Dondi. Caleb, could I talk to you alone for a second, over there, by the window?
等一下，东迪。迦勒，我能和你单独谈谈吗？就在那边，窗户旁边。
Sure, Pete.
当然，皮特。
I will go fetch us some delicious ginger ale.
我去给我们弄点美味的姜汁汽水。
Good idea. What is it, Pete? Think the kid's trying to hustle us?
好主意。怎么了，皮特？觉得那孩子想骗我们？
No, I just wanted to talk, that's all.
不，我只是想聊聊，就这样。
What's the matter?
出什么事了吗？
Nothing. Just I'm afraid of going to hell.
没什么。我只是害怕下地狱。
What? Why?
什么？为什么？
I just don't think I'm a very good person.
我就是觉得我不是个好人。
That's ridiculous, Pete. You're a very nice guy. You write letters. I never write letters.
这太荒谬了，皮特。你是个很好的人。你还会写信。我从不写信。
Yeah, but what if you do something bad? How bad does it have to be? I mean if-- do you have to-- if you feel like it's bad enough to damn you, are you damned? I mean, if you don't feel any remorse?
是啊，但如果你做了坏事呢？要坏到什么程度？我的意思是，如果你觉得自己做的事坏到足以让自己下地狱，那你就是被诅咒了吗？我是说，如果你没有感到任何悔意的话？
Is that it? You betrayed somebody and then didn't feel any remorse? Is that what all those pregnant pauses during the poker banter were about?
原来是这样吗？你背叛了某人却没感到任何悔意？扑克游戏中间那些意味深长的停顿就是因为这个？
Well--
嗯——
How can you say you don't have any remorse when you're practically tearing your hair out worrying about going to hell?
既然你因为担心下地狱而抓狂，怎么能说你没有悔意呢？
But being afraid of punishment isn't the same as remorse. Remorse is truly feeling apologetic for what you've done, not just worrying about being punished for it.
但害怕惩罚并不等同于悔意。悔意是对所做之事发自内心的愧疚，而不仅仅是担心会因此受到惩罚。
And you don't feel sorry at all?
所以你一点也不感到抱歉吗？
No.
是的。
Even though you recognize that what you did was wrong?
即使你认识到自己做错了？
That's right.
没错。
You know, Pete, you're a very complex guy.
你知道吗，皮特，你真是个复杂的人。
Thank you.
谢谢。
They went to sea in a sieve, they did. In a sieve, they went to sea. In spite of all their friends could say, on a winter's morn, on a stormy day, in a seive they went to sea.
他们乘着筛子出海了，真的。他们乘着筛子出了海。尽管朋友们竭力劝阻，在一个冬日的清晨，一个风暴交加的日子，他们乘着筛子出了海。
Dondi, what's with the old lady?
东迪，那个老太太是怎么回事？
The cigar smoke is causing her to recite "The Jumblies" by Edward Lear.
雪茄的烟雾让她开始背诵爱德华·李尔的诗作《珍布利》。
Well, shut her up, will you? I can hardly hear myself think.
嘿，让她闭嘴，好吗？我几乎都听不见自己在想什么了。
Shut up, grandmother.
闭嘴，奶奶。
I mean, what am I doing here? Who are these strange people? I don't remember deciding to come to Italy. What am I doing in Italy?
我是说，我在这儿干什么？这些人是谁？我不记得我决定来意大利了。我在意大利干什么？
Maybe to see the Pope?
也许是去见教皇？
Just last week, I was in France, in Rouen, the town where Joan of Arc was burned at the stake. And I was visiting the tower where she was held before her execution. And I was thinking about writing a letter, you know, apologizing. A letter apologizing to the injured party.
就在上周，我还在法国，在鲁昂，圣女贞德被火刑处死的那个小镇。我参观了她被处决前关押的塔楼。我当时正想写一封信，你知道，道歉。一封向受害者道歉的信。
I was looking down from the highest window in the tower. And just how you do-- you know, you try to tap into the place in yourself where you have truly apologetic feelings, because you want to be sincere. You don't want the letter to sound phony.
我从塔楼最高的窗户往下看。就像你通常做的那样——你知道，你试着去触碰内心深处真正感到愧疚的部分，因为你想表现得真诚。你不想让那封信听起来虚伪。
Except I realized, I discovered that there was no such place in myself, that where that place should have been, there was just an empty hole. And it was frightening. It was like staring into the abyss.
但我意识到，我发现我内心根本没有那个地方，在那本该有愧疚感的地方，只有一个空洞。那太可怕了。就像凝视深渊。
Go see the Pope. Ask for absolution.
去见教皇吧。请求赦免。
But you have to be repentant. I'm not repentant.
但你必须真心忏悔。我没有忏悔。
You could just act repentant. That's what ritual is all about, going through the motions.
你可以装作忏悔。仪式不就是这样吗，走个过场。
No. I'd have to be truly sorry in my heart, or it wouldn't save me.
不。我必须发自内心地真诚悔改，否则那救不了我。
That is a very rigid attitude.
那是一种非常死板的态度。
What do you mean? I can't just pretend to have remorse.
你是什么意思？我不能只是假装悔恨。
You haven't even tried. I mean, the Pope's a very nearsighted, distracted old man. If you buried your face in your hands and pretended to sob, I'm sure he'd buy it.
你甚至都没试过。我是说，教皇是个高度近视、心不在焉的老人。如果你把脸埋在手里假装啜泣，我相信他会信的。
It's not a question of fooling the Pope.
这不仅仅是欺骗教皇的问题。
You know, I'm starting to think that you don't really want to help yourself.
你知道，我开始觉得你根本不想自救。
How did I get here? Why are we playing poker in Italy with a demonic little boy whose grandmother is dying in the next room?
我是怎么到这儿的？为什么我们会在意大利和这群邪恶的小屁孩玩扑克，而他的奶奶还在隔壁房间等死？
[PEACOCK CRY]
[孔雀叫声]
What was that?
那是什么？
[PEACOCK CRY]
[孔雀叫声]
A peacock.
孔雀。
Huh. What's that a symbol of?
哼。那象征着什么？
Pride. Look, there it is, in the middle of the cemetery.
骄傲。看，它在那儿，在墓地中间。
[PEACOCK CRY]
[孔雀叫声]
It's golden, a golden peacock in the middle of a graveyard. I wonder what it means.
它是金色的，墓地中间有一只金孔雀。我在想这意味着什么。
My advice is that you come up with the most positive interpretation you can.
我的建议是你往最积极的方向去解读。
We're out of ginger ale. I can only offer you root beer.
姜汁汽水喝完了。我只能请你喝根汁汽水了。
Oh.
噢。
Aww.
哎呀。
Well, that's all right.
嗯，没关系。
All right, gentlemen. The game is--
好了，各位先生。游戏是——
We know what the game is, you little pistachio masher.
我们知道游戏是什么，你这个搅拌开心果的小东西。
Who dealt this mess?
谁发的这些烂牌？
Don't give me that bluffing baloney. You got a possible straight flush in onions.
别跟我来虚张声势那一套。你的牌里可能有洋葱做成的顺子同花。
Do not mention onions, sahib. My grandfather was killed by Il Duce.
别提洋葱，大人。我的祖父是被墨索里尼害死的。
Don't call me sahib.
别叫我大人。
Talk is cheap, gentlemen. 2 million lira.
空谈误事，先生们。200万里拉。
[PEACOCK CRY]
[孔雀叫声]
Well, "The Golden Peacock" was written for Your Radio Playhouse by Jeff Dorchen. Jeff also played Caleb. Peter Handler played Peter. Lisa Stodder played Dondi and played the dying grandmother.
好的，《金孔雀》是由杰夫·多琴为“你的广播剧场”创作的。杰夫同时也扮演了凯莱布。彼得·汉德勒扮演彼得。丽莎·斯托德扮演唐迪以及那位临终的祖母。
How bad is bad? How bad is bad enough to count to send you to hell? Well, Michael Warr is a local poet and director of the Guild Complex here in Chicago. And he joins us in this, our radio playhouse.
多坏才算坏？坏到什么程度才会被送进地狱？迈克尔·瓦尔是芝加哥本地的一位诗人，也是公会综合体的导演。他加入了我们的广播剧场。
And Michael, you were raised with certain, very particular ideas about when a sin was bad enough to actually count.
迈克尔，你是在某些非常特殊的观念中长大的，关于罪恶要达到什么程度才真的算数。
Yeah. I was raised as a Jehovah's Witness. It was like my whole life was enveloped by what is a sin. And as a Jehovah's Witness, it was Armageddon or paradise.
是的。我是在耶和华见证人的环境中长大的。我的整个生活似乎都被“什么是罪”所笼罩。作为耶和华见证人，未来只有哈米吉多顿或是天堂。
And at a very young age, I decided I did not want to live in paradise because there were these pictures of paradise. The pictures would always be idyllic. And there would be the lion lying with the lamb, everyone sitting around peacefully. And the fascinating thing about the Jehovah's Witnesses, and this is something that affects me to this very day, is that it was a very multicultural type of religion.
在很小的时候，我就决定我不想住在天堂里，因为那些关于天堂的画册。画里的场景总是很田园诗般。狮子与羔羊同卧，每个人都平静地坐着。耶和华见证人最引人入胜的一点——直到今天仍对我产生影响——就是它是一种非常多元文化的宗教。
And so I would look at these pictures. And I noticed that when there were black people in the pictures, that the sisters, their heads were always covered. And that was because there was a political issue that had not really been resolved. And that is in paradise, what would their hair be like?
所以我看着这些画。我注意到当画里有黑人时，姐妹们的头总是被遮住的。这是因为当时有一个尚未真正解决的政治问题。那就是，在天堂里，她们的头发会是什么样子？
See, this is when the natural was a political statement. So that they didn't show them wearing naturals. And believe it or not, this was like a political awakening for me because in high school, these were serious issues. The natural was just like the Black Power sign. It was a political statement. So I said to myself, well, if the sisters can't wear afros in paradise, I don't want to be there.
你看，这就是当“自然发型”成为一种政治宣言的时候。所以他们不展示她们留自然发型的样子。信不信由你，这对我就像是一种政治觉醒，因为在高中时，这些都是严肃的议题。“自然发型”就像黑人权力标志一样。这是一种政治宣言。所以我对自己说，好吧，如果姐妹们在天堂里不能留爆炸头，那我也不想去那里。
Now, you've brought some of your poems about your experience with these rules. And they're here. Actually, you're a very modern poet, and you've brought your color Macintosh, portable Macintosh, here. Why don't we flip it on?
现在，你带了一些关于你在这些规则下的经历的诗。其实你是一位非常现代的诗人，而且你还带来了你的彩色麦金塔便携电脑。我们要不要把它打开？
OK. Let's see if--
好的。看看是不是——
[STARTUP NOISE]
[开机声]
I don't know if you can actually call it a flip, but it's on.
我不知道你能不能称之为“翻开”，但它开了。
It's on.
开了。
Yeah, I have a poem that I have written called "Rules That Don't Work."
是的，我写了一首诗，叫做《行不通的规则》。
Smokey Robinson was a mulatto devil with [? Afro-Motownian ?] rhythm locked inside a black plastic analog disk. Every time he curled his snaking tongue to sing, Satan channeled Motown messages to the epicenter of some sinner's soul, making it shake like the quake in Zechariah, hard as Babylonian tablets and wet as the Red Sea. [SINGING] Baby, baby.
史摩基·罗宾逊是一个有着混血恶魔灵魂的人，心中封锁着黑色塑料模拟唱片里的非裔摩城节奏。每当他弯曲他那蛇一样的舌头唱歌时，撒旦就会把摩城的消息传到某个罪人灵魂的中心，让它像撒迦利亚预言中的地震一样颤抖，像巴比伦泥板一样坚硬，像红海一样潮湿。[歌唱] 宝贝，宝贝。
Slow dancing was wicked. To avoid temptation, we were to dance 18 inches apart, a safe 18 inches.
慢舞是邪恶的。为了避免诱惑，我们要保持18英寸的距离跳舞，安全的18英寸。
On the Oakland side of the bay, black 'hovahs broke all the rules. Having to rebel against something, as other black denominations were breaking windows, tossing Molotovs, and tearing down pillars of the state, they danced, never really measuring the distance between their sacrilegious mounds. Touching more than my ear, that first skintight slow song with sister Sheila Berry was so, so, so evil that a bolt of lightning could have crashed through the roof of that dingy, oil-scented, black-lit ghetto garage and struck me down with the evidence of sin still in my ignorant arms. Dying smiling but confused, not comprehending how her pelvis could be so simultaneously rigid and relaxed, rigid then relaxed, like that thing my father told me not to do. Was it the devil that made her move like that? Sunday morning, I asked my mother and don't remember her giving me an answer.
在海湾的奥克兰一侧，黑人“耶和华见证人”打破了所有规则。因为必须反抗点什么，当其他黑人教派在打破窗户、投掷燃烧瓶、推倒国家支柱时，他们跳着舞，从不真正测量他们亵渎神明的身体之间的距离。在那首与希拉·贝里姐妹共舞的贴身慢歌中，肢体的触碰比我的耳朵感觉到的还要多，那感觉如此之邪恶，一道闪电本可以劈穿那个阴暗的、散发着油味、黑光闪烁的贫民窟车库，将我击倒，让我那无知的怀中依然留存着罪的证据。在困惑中带着微笑死去，不理解为什么她的骨盆可以同时既僵硬又放松，僵硬然后放松，就像我父亲告诉我不准做的那件事。是魔鬼让她那样扭动的吗？周日早上，我问了母亲，我不记得她给了我什么答案。
Do you think that it's only possible to be heavily engaged in these issues, or it's much easier to be heavily engaged in these issues, when you are young? That is, I was talking to this guy about this. And he told me this story about how when he was a kid, not even a teenager yet, he stole a cheap little tin toy car of a kind his parents never would have bought him that he shoplifted out of a dime store.
你认为只有在年轻的时候才可能强烈地参与这些议题，或者说在年轻时更容易参与这些议题吗？我是说，我曾和一个人谈论过这个。他告诉我一个故事，说他小时候，甚至还没到青春期，从杂货店偷了一个他父母永远不会买给他的廉价小铁皮玩具车。
And he said he felt such a profound guilt about the wrongness of this that he could never play with it in good conscience. He could never play with it. And eventually, he just threw it away. He just threw it in the garbage because he thought it was so wrong. And I wondered if you think that our sense of right and wrong is much bigger, our awareness of it, the internal debate about what is right and wrong, is much more acute when we're kids.
他说他感到一种深切的愧疚，觉得自己错了，以至于他无法问心无愧地玩它。他一次都没玩过。最后，他把它扔掉了。他把它扔进了垃圾桶，因为他觉得那太错了。我在想你是否认为我们的对错观念在小时候会更宏大，我们对它的认知、关于对错的内心博弈，在孩子的时候是否更敏锐。
I think that it's far more complicated because you have not formulated your own ideas about what is right, what is wrong. It's totally coming from outside of you. And I think that the environment I was coming up in, in which there was this metaphysical world that I was being force-fed every single day--
我认为这复杂得多，因为你还没有形成自己关于什么是对、什么是错的观念。这些完全是从外界灌输给你的。我认为我成长的那个环境，有一个形而上学的世界，我每天都被强行灌输——
The Witnesses [INAUDIBLE].
见证人[听不清]。
--of my life. Yeah. I mean, I had home Bible study Monday night, public Bible study Tuesday night, home Bible study Wednesday night, training in a theocratic school Thursday night, study of The Watchtower and Awake! at home Friday night, Watchtower and Awake! door-to-door distribution Saturday morning, Sunday morning, and then public lecture Sunday afternoon. That is what you call indoctrination, right?
——我生活中的每一天。是的。我的意思是，我周一晚上有家庭圣经学习，周二晚上有公共圣经学习，周三晚上有家庭圣经学习，周四晚上在神权学校培训，周五晚上在家学习《守望台》和《警醒！》，周六和周日上午去挨家挨户分发《守望台》和《警醒！》，然后周日下午参加公开讲座。这就是你所说的洗脑，对吧？
But on the other hand, there was this other thing going on where I'm reading James Baldwin and reading Malcolm X and literally leading rebellions in high school. In other words, I really didn't have a lot of time beating myself and saying "This is wrong. This is wrong," in terms of buying a Black Panther newspaper or supporting the Black Panthers in those days or something. That might have been considered-- that was a sin for a Jehovah's Witness.
但另一方面，同时发生的另一件事是我在读詹姆斯·鲍德温和马尔科姆·X，并且在高中时确实领导了反叛活动。换句话说，我没有太多时间折磨自己说“这是错的，这是错的”，比如买一份黑豹党的报纸或者在那段日子里支持黑豹党之类的事。对于一个耶和华见证人来说，那可能被认为是一种罪。
But I was convinced by the conditions at the time that hey, if it's a sin, it's the right thing to do. I doubt if I could have explained it that way at the time. But I know I didn't feel guilty about it.
但我当时的状况让我坚信，嘿，如果这是罪，那也是正确的做法。我不确定当时我是否能解释清楚。但我知道我对此并不感到愧疚。
Michael Warr, thank you for coming into our radio playhouse and reading for us.
迈克尔·瓦尔，感谢你来到我们的广播剧场并为我们朗读。
Thank you. It's the most I've talked about the Jehovah's Witnesses in years.
谢谢。这是我多年来谈论耶和华见证人最多的一次。
Michael Warr is the author of We Are the Black Boy. More thoughts about sin, sinning, what's wrong, what's not wrong, when our radio playhouse, my radio playhouse, Your Radio Playhouse continues.
迈克尔·瓦尔是《我们是黑人男孩》的作者。关于罪、犯罪、什么是错、什么不是错的更多思考，当我们的广播剧场，我的广播剧场，你的广播剧场继续时，我们会探讨。
This is Your Radio Playhouse. Small Scale Sin on today's program. I'm Ira Glass.
这是“你的广播剧场”。今天的节目主题是“微型罪恶”。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
So Eli was a big-time computer hacker. He and his friends were thrown into prison for this. He served six months. And here's what he says about his time in the big house.
伊莱曾经是一名顶尖的电脑黑客。他和他的朋友们因此被投入监狱。他服刑了六个月。这是他关于在监狱里那段时光的说法。
It was so fun. I have to say, I had fun. It was a good experience. And I don't regret going there, actually.
太有趣了。我必须说，我玩得很开心。那是一次很好的经历。实际上，我不后悔进去过。
I think a lot of people are going to hear this and feel a certain horror. They're going to feel like, well, people should be punished.
我想很多人听到这些会感到某种恐惧。他们会觉得，好吧，人应该受到惩罚。
Oh yeah. What I did was a bad thing, and I don't suggest anybody else do it, because that would be wrong. I don't do anything illegal anymore.
噢，是的。我做的是一件坏事，我不建议任何人这样做，因为那样是不对的。我不再做任何违法的事了。
This is a story of someone who does not fear hell or punishment. It's a story of somebody who's been put into the position of defining for himself what is right and what is wrong. Starting in the mid-1980s, Eli was a member of a crew of computer hackers called MOD. At the time, journalists from the Village Voice and Esquire magazine documented just how much they were able to do.
这是一个关于不畏惧地狱或惩罚的人的故事。这是一个被置于自己定义对错位置的人的故事。从80年代中期开始，伊莱是一个名为MOD的电脑黑客组织的成员。当时，《乡村之声》和《君子》杂志的记者记录了他们能做到的事情有多惊人。
It is entirely possible that no group of American computer hackers has before or since gotten so far in breaking into other people's computers. They infiltrated dozens of business and government networks. The reporters from Esquire , at one point, asked them to demonstrate their skills by breaking into the White House computer system. And then they watched them do it.
完全有可能，没有哪个美国黑客群体能像他们那样在入侵他人电脑方面走得那么远。他们渗透了数十个商业和政府网络。有一次，《君子》杂志的记者要求他们演示入侵白宫电脑系统的技巧，然后他们就在众目睽睽之下做到了。
But for MOD, their real love was the biggest, most complicated computer system in the world, the phone system. They were in at the highest level computers that run the phone system for New York and New England. And this way, they could assign any services to any phone, listen to any phone, disconnect or create accounts, get unlisted phone numbers, or bring the entire phone system down.
但对于MOD来说，他们真正的挚爱是世界上最大、最复杂的电脑系统——电话系统。他们进入了纽约和新英格兰地区电话系统的顶级电脑服务器。通过这种方式，他们可以为任何电话分配服务、监听任何电话、断开或创建账户、获取未公开的电话号码，或者让整个电话系统瘫痪。
Eli served six months in a minimum-security prison and six months on home confinement. I spoke with him this summer, while he was still on home confinement in his parents' house in Queens.
伊莱在最低安全级别的监狱服刑了六个月，并在家执行了六个月的居家监禁。今年夏天，当他还在皇后区他父母家里接受居家监禁时，我和他进行了交谈。
The prison I had gone to was very relaxed. We played tennis, basketball. We had tournaments and got trophies. It was at Allenwood FPC. And playing Monopoly with the other inmates and Scrabble and stuff, it was just a wild concept.
我去的那个监狱非常放松。我们打网球、打篮球。我们还举办锦标赛并获得奖杯。那是在艾伦伍德联邦惩教所。和狱友们玩大富翁、拼字游戏之类的，这真是一个疯狂的概念。
And then when I came back here, it actually bummed me out that I had to be home all day. It was like, where does this make sense? They're doing me a favor by letting me out, yet I had more fun in there. Something's not right. Something was very not right.
然后当我回到家时，我必须整天待在家里，这反而让我感到沮丧。就像是，这算哪门子道理？他们放我出来是给我恩惠，可我在里面却玩得更开心。有什么地方不对劲。有什么地方非常不对劲。
It was more like a fame camp. People who were known and people who were involved in high-profile cases went there. That's what it was.
那更像是一个名人夏令营。那些知名人士和卷入高调案件的人都去了那里。情况就是这样。
I had a couple of really good friends there. My best friend there was a fellow by the name of Chris who lived out in San Diego and was involved in marijuana dealing. And he used to sell it through the mail. And he got caught. And they took away about $350,000 from him. And he's my age, probably 23, 24, something like that.
我在那儿有几个很好的朋友。我最好的朋友是一个叫克里斯的人，他住在圣地亚哥，因贩卖大麻而入狱。他过去经常通过邮件销售大麻。他被抓住了。他们没收了他大约35万美元。他和我同龄，大概23、24岁左右。
And it was sad that he got five years. He was a nice guy. He was just like me. And we would hang out all the time.
他被判了五年，这很可悲。他是个好人。他和我一模一样。我们经常待在一起。
And across from me on the other side of my room was a man they used to call the Condo King. And he lived in Massachusetts in a castle that was probably worth $5 million and had butlers and Rolls Royces and this and that. And it was a real castle and right on the water.
在我房间对面的那个人，他们以前叫他“公寓之王”。他在马萨诸塞州住在一座价值可能达500万美元的城堡里，有管家、劳斯莱斯等等。那真的是一座城堡，而且就在水边。
And he taught me about real estate, which was the funny thing. So I learned real estate from him. I learned about stocks. I learned from the best. And it was such a great experience. It was like college all over again.
他教了我房地产知识，这挺有意思的。我从他那里学到了房地产，还学到了股票。我跟着最优秀的人学习，那真是一段很棒的经历，感觉就像重回大学一样。
The attitude there was that of camaraderie. Everybody there had this one thing in common, and that was that they looked for the shortest way possible to achieve what they wanted to achieve. And they all got there at some point. And they just felt a stroke of bad luck, I suppose.
那里的人有一种同志般的情谊。大家都有一个共同点：都在寻找实现目标的最快捷径。他们最终都达到了目的，我想他们只是运气不好才被抓进来的。
There were no losers there, that's for sure. Everybody there had achieved a very high level of success, were very well known in whatever they did. And I was friends with all the mobsters there. And they took care of me and stuff because I was from New York and I knew about Little Italy and Mulberry and the Village and stuff.
那里绝对没有失败者。每个人都在各自的领域取得了非常高的成就，知名度也很高。我和那些黑帮分子关系不错。他们挺照顾我的，因为我来自纽约，熟悉小意大利、马尔伯里和村子那边的情况。
And when I went there, it was like, hey, another guy from New York. Kid's from the streets. And they were just impressed because I was the only hacker in this whole compound. So everybody knew me. As soon as I got there, a day later, everybody was blabbing, hey, there's this hacker in here. Even the guards were telling the inmates, hey, that guy's in here for this.
当我到那里时，他们就像是说：“嘿，又来了一个纽约客，这小子是街头混出来的。”他们对我很佩服，因为我是整个监狱里唯一的黑客。所以大家都认识我。我刚到那里一天，大家就都在议论：“嘿，这里有个黑客。”甚至连狱警都会告诉其他囚犯：“嘿，那家伙就是因为这个进来的。”
Outside, in the hacking community, Eli was pretty well known. Actually, he was known by his handle, which was Acid Phreak. That's "Phreak" with a P-H at the beginning of it. Inside, in prison, he got all sorts of job offers. It turns out that lots of people in prison can use the services of a computer hacker.
在外面的黑客圈子里，Eli相当有名。其实他更广为人知的代号是“Acid Phreak”，也就是“Phreak”，以P-H开头。在监狱里，他收到了各种各样的工作邀请。事实证明，监狱里很多人都能用得上电脑黑客的服务。
Everything from obtaining credit cards to changing credit to-- yeah, changing credit was a big thing. Because, I don't know if you know about this, but every time these real estate guys get busted, their credit usually goes down the tubes. One big request I had was to change a lot of credit reports and stuff. And I didn't do that and didn't take it seriously. I just told them, yeah, it was possible, but you're not going to get it from me.
从获取信用卡信息到修改信用记录——是的，修改信用记录可是件大事。因为我不知道你清不清楚，这些房地产商每次被抓，信用记录通常都会一落千丈。我收到的一个大请求就是修改大量的信用报告之类的数据。但我没做，也没把它当回事。我只是告诉他们：“是的，理论上可行，但你别想从我这里得到帮助。”
And there was a lot of mobsters who wanted me to set up phone lines for them that couldn't be detected by the police and things like that. And again, "Well, it's possible. But I can't do that for you." But then again, if you were to ask me that and I was to do it, I wouldn't tell you anyway. So that's kind of a question that's hard to answer.
还有很多黑帮分子想让我为他们架设警察无法追踪的电话线之类的事情。我还是那句话：“嗯，理论上可行，但我不能为你做。”但话又说回来，如果你问我这些而我真的做了，我也不会告诉你的。所以这其实是个很难回答的问题。
Come into my domain. This is my room. As you can see, it's a typical teenager room.
进入我的领域吧，这是我的房间。如你所见，这就是典型的青少年房间。
Well, actually, it was only sort of typical. The bedroom that he lives in during his six-month home confinement is tiny, barely enough space for a bed, a desk, and a bookshelf. There's a TV and a VCR, two computers. He flips on the stereo.
好吧，其实它只能算是“稍微”典型一点。他在六个月居家监禁期间住的这间卧室非常小，几乎只能放下一张床、一张桌子和一个书架。房间里有一台电视、一台录像机和两台电脑。他打开了音响。
I don't know. I guess I've got kind of a lot of equipment around here. I've got a fax machine here. In my room, I've got five phone lines. I got a two-line phone, but I've got everything else connected to computers or fax.
我不知道，我想我周围的设备实在太多了。我这儿有一台传真机，我的房间里装了五条电话线。我有一部双线电话，但其他所有东西都连着电脑或传真机。
There were cheesy kung fu movies on video. On his CD player, there was old-school rap, Nine Inch Nails, the Doors, Jimi Hendrix. And then he says, "Let me show you the good stuff," and he pulls out Xeroxes of old spiral notebooks.
视频带里放着俗气的功夫片。他的CD机里有老派饶舌、九寸钉乐队、门户乐队和吉米·亨德里克斯的歌。然后他说：“让我给你们看点好东西。”接着他掏出了几份旧螺旋笔记本的复印件。
I have here what was seized from me but they had to return back to me. Here's my evidence examination report by the United States Secret Service. Subject, Acid Phreak. These notes have basically all the systems I got into. Look, I have little sketches and diagrams of how things work, different protocols and networks, definitions. See, a lot of this stuff was really good. I had stuff outside the country, NASA.
这是从我这儿扣押的东西，但他们后来不得不还给我。这是美国特勤局给我的证据审查报告，主题是“Acid Phreak”。这些笔记里基本上记录了我进入过的所有系统。你看，我有关于事物运行方式的小草图和图表，各种协议和网络，还有定义。看，很多东西真的很棒。我甚至连国外的系统都进过，比如NASA的。
The something defense? What is that?
那个什么防御系统？那是什么？
Government defense.
政府防御系统。
Yeah, that's a Washington number. McDonald's, since I had Telenet, I had McDonald's accounts. If you're a McDonald's employee, I could raise your pay. So that way, you get $15 an hour for shuffling burgers and stuff.
是的，那是华盛顿的号码。麦当劳的，因为我有Telenet，我有麦当劳的账号。如果你是麦当劳员工，我可以帮你涨工资。这样一来，你就能每小时挣15美元去翻汉堡包之类的了。
So did you decide just at random to help someone out?
那你当时是随机决定帮某人一把的吗？
I didn't do it to anybody. I just wanted to know how.
我没帮过任何人，我只是想知道原理而已。
We did this from pay phones. We'd have a line of pay phones. We'd get into the computer, first liberate one phone. "Liberating" meaning make it so that you don't need quarters for that pay phone. You just pick up and dial like a regular house phone. So that way, we could make an endless amount of phone calls without putting quarters.
我们是在公用电话亭做这些事的。我们会找一排公用电话，先入侵电脑，解放其中一部电话。“解放”的意思是让你打电话不需要投币。你只需拿起听筒就能拨号，就像普通的家用电话一样。这样我们就可以无休止地打电话而不用投币。
Next step was to get into the network, find a session that was already going, and then knock them off while they were connected, and then sit there, watching them. In other words, put us in the place of the computer they were going to connect to. So the next time they'd try to log in, they would get our computer. And we'd type in, "login." And they'd put in their login account.
下一步是进入网络，找到一个正在进行的会话，然后在他们连接时把他们踢下去，然后坐在那里盯着看。换句话说，把自己放在他们要连接的计算机的位置上。这样下次他们尝试登录时，他们连接的就是我们的电脑。我们会输入“login（登录）”，他们就会输入自己的账号。
Then we'd go, "password," you know? The password. They'd say, "OK, password," and they'd put their password in. And then we would have-- all these things were already encoded in one key, so we could just hit one key. And it wouldn't look like we were typing it.
然后我们输入“password（密码）”，你知道的，就是密码。他们会说：“好的，密码。”然后他们就会输入自己的密码。我们当时已经把这些步骤编码在一个按键里了，所以只需按一下键就行。这样看起来就不像是我们在打字。
Login would just appear, whoomp. Input password, whoomp.
“登录”会自动弹出，砰。输入密码，砰。
Login. And then we'd hit the password key, and password would come out. And then we'd say "Login incorrect" and then disconnect from them. But we already got their login and password.
登录。然后我们按下密码键，密码就会显示出来。接着我们说“登录错误”，然后切断连接。但我们已经拿到了他们的账号和密码。
And then when they reconnected, it would be the regular system. So they'd figure, hey, I made a mistake typing it in or something. And that's how we would get in accounts. It was funny.
等他们重新连接时，就是正规系统了。所以他们会觉得，嘿，我可能打错字了或者什么之类的。这就是我们获取账号的方法。挺有意思的。
You get into things that are good. You start targeting systems that are interesting. And then you start developing a collection. It's like baseball cards. I have NASA. I have NSA. I've got the phone company computers. I've got MISR. I've got Cosmos. I've got this. I've got that.
当你进入了那些不错的系统，就开始寻找有趣的系统为目标，然后开始建立你的收藏。就像棒球卡一样。我有NASA的，有NSA的，有电话公司的电脑，有MISR的，有Cosmos的，这个我有，那个我也有。
McDonnell-Douglas, Marriott Marietta. TRW, CBI, TransUnion. What else can I get? You try to get the big names. So you start developing your collection.
麦道公司、马里奥特、马里埃塔。TRW、CBI、环联。我还能弄到什么？你会尝试去弄那些大公司的账号。所以你开始建立你的收藏。
Then after a while, it became fun to look up famous people. Let's look up John Gotti's credit. Let's see what he owns. Let's look up Julia Roberts. Let's get her home phone number. Let's get this guy's home phone number.
过了一段时间，搜索名人变得很有趣。查查约翰·戈蒂的信用记录，看看他拥有什么。查查茱莉亚·罗伯茨，拿到她的家庭电话号码，或者其他人的电话号码。
We'd go into pay phones and stuff. And hooking up, I would drive up to a pay phone real quick and do what I had to do and leave really quick. That's where I really got into a movie. I felt like it was like Mission: Impossible, like that whole gang. It was like-- [HUMMING "MISSION: IMPOSSIBLE THEME"].
我们会去公用电话亭之类的。至于连接网络，我会开车飞快地停在公用电话亭边，做完我该做的事然后迅速离开。那感觉真的像在拍电影，我觉得就像《碟中谍》那群人一样。就像是——[哼唱《碟中谍》主题曲]。
And we would all go out and hook up and everything. And it was like, "Yeah, all right. I'm that black guy who does all this technical stuff. I can get into it. Let's go, let's go."
我们都会出去连接网络，一切都像是在说：“太棒了。我是那个搞定所有技术难题的黑人小伙。我可以攻进去。走，快走。”
I felt like we should have walkie-talkies and headsets and everything, and be like, "OK, Blue. Go do your thing on five. Ready? Five, four three, you're in. You're in." It was just amazing after a while. And we were just so excited we were getting all that stuff. And it was just a rush. It was the flow.
我觉得我们应该配上对讲机和耳机之类的，然后说：“好的，Blue。去执行你的任务，五号线。准备好了吗？五、四、三，你进去了。你进去了。”过了一段时间，这简直太不可思议了。我们当时太兴奋了，能弄到所有这些东西。那是一种冲击感，一种心流。
Once you start going, you can't stop. You're just steamrolling one after the other. And the flow gets you going, and then you're just like, "Yeah, we rule. We're it." It breaks down all barriers. Nothing can stop the flow. If you've got the flow, you can conquer everything. That's what people call being in the zone. Once you're in there, you can't stop. It's the juice.
一旦你开始行动，你就停不下来。你就像压路机一样一个接一个地碾过去。心流驱动着你前进，你会觉得：“没错，我们掌控一切。我们就是老大。”它打破了所有障碍。没有什么能阻止这种心流。如果你进入了这种状态，你就能征服一切。这就是人们所说的“进入状态”。一旦进入，你就停不下来。这就是那种快感。
If anything, it's surprising how little they did with their power over computers. It was mostly pranks, making somebody's phone ring continuously, turning an enemy's home phone line into a pay phone line so when the guy picked up his phone at home, it demanded that he deposit a quarter. Of course, there was no way he could do that because it's his home phone.
甚至可以说，令人惊讶的是，他们利用对计算机的掌控权所做的事情竟然如此微不足道。大多是些恶作剧，比如让某个人的电话不停地响，或者把仇人的家用电话线变成公用电话线，这样当那个人在家接起电话时，电话就会要求他投币。当然，他根本没法投，因为那是他家里的电话。
They did actually call Julia Roberts once. They called Queen Elizabeth, too. But there's an emptiness at the heart of a lot of these stories. Once you've got the Queen on the phone, what do you say?
他们确实给茱莉亚·罗伯茨打过一次电话。他们也给英国女王打过电话。但这些故事的核心其实是很空虚的。一旦你真的接通了女王的电话，你要说什么呢？
She's like, "Hello?" She's talking to us and stuff. And we don't know what to say. "Hi, we're calling from the United States, and this and that." And she knew what was up. She's like, "OK, hello." And then she said goodbye, and that was it.
她说：“喂？”她在跟我们说话，但我们不知道该说什么。“嗨，我们从美国打来的，这个那个的。”她知道是怎么回事，她说：“好的，喂。”然后她就挂了，就这么简单。
We didn't know what to say. What do you say to Queen Elizabeth? "Hi. So you see that movie, True Lies?" You know, what do you say? The fun of it is finding the number.
我们根本不知道要说什么。你对英国女王说什么？“嗨，你看过《真实的谎言》那部电影吗？”你知道，能说什么呢？乐趣在于找到号码本身。
Eli was thrown into prison for a relatively minor offense. Some of the members of his crew broke into the computers that list everybody's credit ratings. And they copied some credit reports. And they sold the information to other people. And he was named as a member of this conspiracy.
Eli因为一起相对较轻的罪行被投入监狱。他团队中的一些成员闯入了记录每个人信用评级的电脑系统，复制了一些信用报告，并将这些信息卖给他人。而他也被指控为这起阴谋的一员。
They said we abused our power. But we didn't abuse it at all. We did nothing compared to the things that could have been done. What we did was such a small thing in such a larger scheme of things.
他们说我们滥用职权，但我们根本没有滥用。比起那些本可以做的事情，我们做的简直微不足道。在更大的蓝图中，我们所做的只是沧海一粟。
It's kind of depressing, in a way. There's so many things we could have done. We could have monitored Peter Lynch. What's the next best investment for the day? And we'd make millions of dollars investing or shorting some stock. But we never did. And now we wonder why. We're like, "Damn. There are so many applications for this kind of stuff. What happened?" But then we're like, "Ah, we were just kids."
某种程度上这挺令人沮丧的。我们本可以做很多事情，比如监控彼得·林奇，看看今天最好的投资是什么，然后通过做多或做空股票赚几百万美元。但我们从来没这样做过。现在我们想知道为什么。我们在想：“该死，这种事情有这么多应用场景。到底发生了什么？”但接着我们又想：“啊，我们当时只是孩子。”
Then one time, one of us got the Mad magazine owner's phone number. And we called him. And that time, he was going through some rough times or something. And we were calling him for about two weeks. And he was just so goofy. He was kind of crazy. And he was just really stressed or something. And we just kept calling him and calling him.
还有一次，我们中有人弄到了《疯狂》杂志所有者的电话号码。我们给他打电话。那段时间他好像正经历一些困难，我们连续两周给他打电话。他当时看起来傻乎乎的，有点疯狂，而且压力非常大。我们就一直给他打电话，一直打。
And finally, we started harassing him and harassing him. We'd make fun of him and laugh at him and call him Alfred E. Neuman. And just ridicule him. And then he got so mad at us. And we used to keep calling and screwing around with him.
最后，我们开始骚扰他，嘲笑他，叫他“阿尔弗雷德·E·纽曼”，对他进行冷嘲热讽。他被我们气坏了，而我们以前经常打电话捉弄他。
And then one day, we read in a paper he died. The day after we had called him, he passes away. And we're there like, "Yo, did we kill him? I hope not." And then they said he had some nervous breakdown and this and that. We're like, "Oh my god. Oh my god. I think we contributed to his demise there. We better not tell anybody this." But then we realized that there was probably other factors that contributed to it, not just a kid calling him on the phone. But since then, we stopped doing things like that because it was like, "Oh my god."
后来有一天，我们在报纸上看到他去世了。就在我们给他打过电话的第二天，他就去世了。我们当时想：“天哪，是我们害死他的吗？我希望不是。”后来他们说他当时精神崩溃了什么的。我们想：“天哪，天哪。我觉得是我们导致了他的死亡。我们最好别告诉任何人。”但后来我们意识到，可能还有其他因素导致了他的死亡，不仅仅是一个孩子打来的电话。但从那以后，我们就不再做那种事了，因为那感觉太可怕了。
I don't destroy computers. I don't take them down. I don't delete information that shouldn't be deleted. I think there's something morally wrong if you affect a person personally in not only his computer life, but his personal life, his right to make a living. I think that's wrong. It's just a question of morality.
我不破坏电脑。我不搞垮它们。我不删除不该删除的信息。我认为如果你不仅在电脑生活，还在个人生活、谋生权利方面对一个人造成影响，那是道德上有问题的。我认为那是错的，这纯粹是道德问题。
One thing about the computer world is that it's all so new. And hacking on computers is so new that each person who does it feels like he or she can create his or her own moral code. And Eli's crew had its own particular code of behavior. For example, unlike most hackers, they didn't share what they knew with other hackers.
电脑世界的一大特点是它太新了。黑客入侵计算机这件事太新了，以至于每个做这件事的人都觉得自己可以创建自己的道德准则。Eli的团队有自己特殊的行为准则。例如，与其他大多数黑客不同，他们并不与其他人分享他们所知道的东西。
We had complete control over certain networks. We could have any system we wanted on that network. Any host was ours. But you don't let it get out to other hacking groups and other hackers. Because if they don't know how to use it, they don't understand the power of it all, you can't trust them. It's too much power for some people.
我们对某些网络拥有完全控制权。在那个网络上，我们可以进入任何系统，任何主机都是我们的。但你不能让它泄露给其他黑客组织或个人。因为如果他们不知道如何使用，不了解这背后的力量，你就不能信任他们。对某些人来说，这力量太大了。
Basically, it's like having a gun. Let's say it's the Wild West. You take it upon yourself to have a gun, you're responsible for it. If you give that to someone, you're responsible for that. So you don't give it out. If you want to shoot somebody's sister, somebody's wife or something, that's upon you. It's all a question of morality in my eyes.
基本上，这就像拥有一把枪。假设这是在西部荒野，你决定携带一把枪，你就得对它负责。如果你把它交给别人，你也得负责。所以你不能随便交给别人。如果你想去射杀别人的姐妹、妻子或什么人，那是你自己的责任。在我眼里，这一切都是道德问题。
And if I know something, and it's of importance to somebody else, who's to tell me I can't sell it if I know it? Like if I knew something about you that somebody would pay a price for, it's up to me and my own morality whether I would sell it to him or not. But nobody could tell me, "You can't do that."
如果我知道某些事情，而且这对别人很重要，谁能告诉我说，如果我知道了我就不能出卖它？就像如果我知道关于你的某些事，而有人愿意出钱购买，那么我是否卖给他，完全取决于我和我自己的道德标准。但没有人能告诉我：“你不能那样做。”
Like if I know about your credit history, and somebody comes up to me and says, "I'm doing background on him. I want to know. Can you get me his credit history?" If I think it's immoral, I'm not going to do it. But if for some reason I think that he's going to get it anyway, and it would benefit me, I'd probably give it to him anyway.
比如如果我知道你的信用记录，有人过来对我说：“我正在调查他的背景，我想知道。你能帮我拿到他的信用记录吗？”如果我认为这不道德，我就不会去做。但如果出于某种原因，我觉得无论如何他都能拿到，而且这对我有利，我可能还是会给他。
We're not evil people. We're good people at heart. There was a time when me and my friend, Nynex Phreak, another guy in the group, we found a system that actually, what it did was you could input a certain series of digits. It would take those digits and see if it was a credit card. So you could basically hack out credit card numbers just by guessing. Is this a credit card? And it would tell you if it was or not. And we found that system.
我们不是邪恶的人，我们本质上是好人。曾经有一次，我和我的朋友Nynex Phreak（组里的另一个人），我们发现了一个系统，你输入一串数字，它会判断这些数字是否是信用卡。所以你基本上可以通过猜测来“黑出”信用卡号码。这是信用卡吗？它会告诉你是不是。我们发现了那个系统。
Finally, somebody wrote a program that would automatically do it, scan all night and get thousands of credit cards. And we're like, yeah, this is no good. What if they start selling credit cards and stuff? We're like, this is no good. So we actually called the FBI and told them about it.
最后，有人写了一个程序可以自动完成这个过程，整晚扫描并获取数以千计的信用卡号。我们想，不行，这太糟糕了。如果他们开始兜售信用卡怎么办？我们想，这太糟糕了。所以我们实际上给联邦调查局打了电话，告诉了他们这件事。
We wouldn't narc on anybody. We wouldn't say who wrote it or anything. We just said, there's a system, and it isn't right it's open like that. It was just getting ridiculous.
我们不会举报任何人，我们不会说是谁写的或者其他什么信息。我们只是说，有一个系统，这样公开是不对的。这简直太离谱了。
So I was like, "We've got to put an end to this." And we did that. And we were like, "Damn. We can't tell any hacker we did this. They'll be pissed." And we felt like that was right to do. That's kind of wrong.
所以我当时想：“我们必须结束这一切。”我们确实做到了。我们当时想：“该死，我们不能告诉任何黑客我们做了这件事。他们会气疯的。”但我们觉得这样做是正确的。那样做是错的。
It is because of their own moral code in their group, and also their belief that someday hacking will no longer be seen as a crime, that society will change its ideas about information and computers and breaking into computers, that Eli is able to say something like this next quote about his time in the big house.
正因为他们团队内部有自己的道德准则，加上他们认为终有一天黑客行为将不再被视为犯罪，社会对信息、电脑以及入侵电脑的观念将会改变，Eli才能说出接下来这句关于他“坐牢”期间的话。
I was a criminal in the sense that Jesus Christ was a criminal, you know? Well, you know how he was thought to be a criminal. And he was sentenced and everything. And now look. Everybody's sporting crosses. And there's churches built around him and everything. Who knows? Maybe one day, it'll be Acid Phreak, the faith. You never know.
从某种意义上说，我是个罪犯，就像耶稣基督也是个罪犯，你知道吧？好吧，你知道人们曾认为他是罪犯。他被判刑等等。但现在看看吧，每个人都戴着十字架，周围建起了教堂。谁知道呢？也许有一天，Acid Phreak会变成一种信仰。你永远不知道。
In fact, when I was visiting Eli, he was facing a daily question of right and wrong when it came to his own home confinement. The prison system was keeping track of him during home confinement with this electronic device. It was about the size of a beeper. It was riveted onto an ankle strap.
事实上，当我去探访Eli时，他在居家监禁方面正面临着每天关于对与错的拷问。监狱系统在他居家监禁期间用这种电子设备跟踪他。它大约有寻呼机那么大，铆在脚踝的绑带上。
And it would send this signal to a computer that authorities had put into his house. And that computer would call another computer any time that he would leave the house. And as he explained, hacking these computers and the phone line that connected them was pretty easy work.
它会向当局安装在他家里的电脑发送信号。只要他离开家，那台电脑就会拨打另一台电脑的电话。正如他所解释的，入侵这些电脑和连接它们的电话线简直是轻而易举。
But he did not do it. He said he just didn't want to get in any more trouble. He said he was going straight. And it wasn't because he thought hacking was wrong. It was that he was just tired of it.
但他没有那样做。他说他只是不想再惹麻烦了，他说他要走正道。这并不是因为他认为黑客行为是错的，而是他真的厌倦了。
We had lists and lists of computers and no time to do it in. It just got to the point where it was such a large burden. It was like, "Aw, man. We got to do this one. Aw, there's another one we got to do." And then it got to hundreds and hundreds. And finally, it's not even fun anymore.
我们有成堆的电脑列表，却根本没时间去操作。这已经成为一种沉重的负担。就像是：“噢，伙计，我们得搞定这一台。噢，还有另一台要搞。”然后数量变成成百上千。最后，这甚至一点也不好玩了。
It was such a rush to get it when you initially get it. But then, I don't know. It gets to be boring. I've just burned myself out, I think. I just got to that point where everybody gets burnt out if they have a little too much of everything.
刚开始得到它们时，那种冲动非常强烈。但后来，我不知道，变得很无聊。我想我已经筋疲力尽了。我只是到了那种人如果得到太多东西就会精疲力竭的地步。
Now, though he was burned out, it was still a shock when the federal authorities seized all of his computers and he wasn't allowed to hack anymore. This was back when he was first arrested.
不过现在，虽然他已经筋疲力尽了，但当联邦当局没收了他所有的电脑，且不再允许他进行黑客活动时，他依然感到非常震惊。那是在他刚被捕的时候。
It was like, OK, what do I do? I usually get on the computer now, late at night and stuff. And you'd just go to sleep. And then my lifestyle started changing. I'd be sleeping at night again. So I was like, "Damn. This is like-- I have to fill this void. What should I do?" And I didn't know what to do anymore. It was horrible.
当时就像是：“好吧，我该做什么？”以前我通常在深夜之类的时刻用电脑。而现在你只能去睡觉了。于是我的生活方式开始改变。我开始在晚上睡觉。所以我想：“该死，这就像……我必须填补这个空虚。我该做什么？”我再也不知道该做什么了，这太可怕了。
It was sad. We would call each other up. And usually, we'd be talking about computers and trading passwords, and then we'd get into this and that. And I remember, the first time we called, it was like, "So, what's up?" "Nothing. I cleaned my room yesterday." "Yeah, they came over and cleaned my room, too, pretty well." "Yeah, I know." "So what do you want to do?" "I don't know."
这很悲哀。我们会互相打电话。通常我们聊的都是关于电脑、交换密码，然后聊聊这个那个。我记得第一次通电话时，就像是：“最近怎么样？”“没啥。我昨天打扫房间了。”“是啊，他们也过来把我房间彻底打扫了一遍。”“我知道。”“那你想做什么？”“我不知道。”
Because it's such a large part of our lives at that point. You have so much power and to lose it in an instant like that is just such a shock. It's like, bam. You don't have that power anymore. You can't sit on your computer. What are you going to do? Uh-oh, I'm a regular guy now. I'm not Acid Phreak anymore. What's Acid Phreak without a computer? He's just a regular guy. So it was a bummer.
因为当时电脑是我们生活的重要组成部分。你拥有如此多的力量，瞬间失去它是一种巨大的冲击。就像是，砰。你再也没有那种力量了。你不能坐在电脑前。你要做什么？噢，现在我是个普通人了。我不再是Acid Phreak了。没有电脑的Acid Phreak算什么？他只是个普通人。所以那真是令人沮丧。
At this point, I've already done it. I see it as a teenager thing. OK, I was a hacker when I was a kid and this and that. I got busted. It's a teenager thing to do. And that's that. I move on. I work with computers now, and that's my life.
现在，我已经经历过这一切了。我把它看作是青少年的事情。好吧，我小时候是个黑客，这个那个的。我被抓了。这是年轻人会做的事，就这样。我继续前行，我现在用电脑工作，这就是我的生活。
Well, Acid Phreak was not the first criminal who told me that he quit being bad because he got bored with it. A few Chicago gang members have told me the same thing, that you end up having the same night over and over again. You just get tired of it.
嗯，Acid Phreak并不是第一个告诉我他因为厌倦而停止作恶的罪犯。几名芝加哥黑帮成员也对我这么说过，你会发现日子过得千篇一律，最终你只是厌倦了。
Maybe you remember the book A Clockwork Orange, the book and the movie. They're about teenage boys who love ultra-violence, commit murder, do all sorts of horrible things, speak to each other in a very stylized language.
也许你还记得《发条橙》这本书和电影。讲的是一群热爱暴力、犯下谋杀罪、做各种可怕事情的少年，他们用一种非常有风格的语言交谈。
At the end of that book-- the movie actually doesn't end this way, but the original British edition of the novel does. At the end of the book, the central character gives up committing acts of violence. And it's not because he thinks it's wrong. And it's not because any of the punishments and treatments that he's received have worked on him.
在书的结尾——电影其实不是这样结尾的，但原版英国小说是这样的——书的中心人物放弃了暴力行为。这并不是因为他认为那是错的，也不是因为他所受的任何惩罚或治疗对他起了作用。
He gives it up because he's bored with it. It's just not that interesting to him. And we will end our program today with a couple of paragraphs from the book.
他放弃是因为他厌倦了。这对他来说不再有趣了。今天节目最后，我们将用书中的几段话来结束。
"I knew what was happening, O my brothers. I was like growing up. Yes yes yes, there it is. Youth must go. Ah, yes. But youth is only being in a way like it might be an animal. No, it is not just like being an animal so much as being like one of those malenky toys you viddy being sold in the streets, like little chellovecks made out of tin, with a spring inside and then a winding handle on the outside. And you wind it up, grrr grrr grrr and off it itties, like walking, O my brothers. But it itties in a straight line. And it bangs straight into things, bang bang. And it cannot help what it is doing. Being young is like being one of those malenky machines."
“我知道发生了什么，我的兄弟们。我好像长大了。是的，是的，就是这样。青春终将逝去。啊，是的。但青春在某种意义上就像是一种动物。不，与其说像动物，不如说像你在街上看到的那些廉价玩具，就像锡做的、带发条的小人，内部有个弹簧，外面有个把手。你拧紧它，嘎吱嘎吱，它就跑了，像是在走路，我的兄弟们。但它走的是直线。它会直直地撞向物体，砰，砰。它无法控制自己的行为。年轻就像是那些廉价机器。”
And then at this point, the narrator starts going into this fantasy about having a son someday. And he says, "When I had my son, I would like to explain all that to him, when he was starry enough to like understand. But then I knew he would not understand, or would not want to understand at all, and would do all the veshches I had done, yes perhaps even killing some poor starry forella surrounded with mewing kots and koshkas. And I would not be able to really stop him. And nor would he be able to stop his own son, brothers. And so it would itty on like that to the end of the world, round and round and round, like some bolshy, gigantic like chelloveck, like old Bog Himself, turning and turning and turning, a vonny grahzny orange in his gigantic rookers."
说到这里，旁白开始幻想未来有个儿子。他说：“当我有了儿子，如果他足够聪明能听懂，我会向他解释这一切。但我知道他不会理解，或者根本不想理解，他会做我做过的所有事情，甚至可能杀死某个被猫咪环绕的可怜的老妇人。我也无法真正阻止他。他也无法阻止他自己的儿子，兄弟们。一切就这样一直持续到世界尽头，不停地循环往复，就像那个巨大的人类，像上帝本人，旋转、旋转、旋转，手里拿着一个又臭又脏的橙子。”
Well, this episode of Your Radio Playhouse was produced by WBEZ Chicago with generous funding from the MacArthur Foundation. Editorial and production help from Paul Tough and Jack Hitt on the East Coast, Margy Rochlin on the West Coast, Dolores Wilber and Emily Hanford here in Chicago. It was Paul Tough who hooked up the program with all the computer hackers. The old gospel records today were courtesy of the amazing Steve Cushing and the Blues Before Sunrise radio network. Rob Newhouse helped produce our radio play. Special thanks, as always, to Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
好了，本期《你的广播剧场》节目由WBEZ芝加哥制作，并获得了麦克阿瑟基金会的慷慨资助。编辑和制作由东海岸的Paul Tough和Jack Hitt、西海岸的Margy Rochlin、以及芝加哥的Dolores Wilber和Emily Hanford协助完成。是Paul Tough将节目与所有计算机黑客联系起来的。今天的旧福音唱片由令人惊叹的Steve Cushing和Blues Before Sunrise广播网提供。Rob Newhouse帮助制作了我们的广播剧。一如既往地特别感谢Torey Malatia。我是Ira Glass。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
This is WBEZ Chicago.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥。